فجاه ومن دون سابق انذار انتهى نزاع استمر
ثمانيه عشر شهرا بين شركتي ايرباص والخطوط
الجويه القطريه لم تكن المعركه بين
الشركتين قصه عاديه فلم يسبق ان دخلت شركه
طيران في معركه طاحنه مع اكبر شركه لصناعه
الطائره
بدا الخلاف عندما اشتكت القطريه من سلامه
طائرات الجيل الجديد اي 35 وقالت ان اسطح
الطائرات متاكله وان التلف الطلائي كشف عن
وجود فجوات لا تحمي من الصواعق واقرت
بوجود عيوب في الجوده لكنها اصرت مدعومه
من الجهات التنظيميه الاوروبيه على ان
الطائرات امنه واتهمت القطريه بالمبالغه
في العيوب لكسب تعويض اتجه الخلاف نحو
المحاكم البريطانيه حيث اصبحت تفاصيل
الدعاوى معلنه في قطاع يحظى عاده بالسريه
نظرا لحساسيه قطاع الطيران
التصعيد دفع ايرباص الى الغاء الصفقات مع
قطر بمليارات الدولارات تاركه للقطريه
خيارا واحدا لشراء طائراتها من بوي وكان
للطرفين مطالبات متبادله مجمعه بلغت
قيمتها نحو مليارين دولار قبل المحاكمه
التي كانت مقرره في يونيو
وبموجب التسويه الجديده اعادت ايرباص
تفعيل الطلبات الملغات التي تشمل 23 طائره
من طراز اي 35 لم تسلم و50 طائره اصغر من
طراز اي 3 2020
من الدولارات لشركه الطيران الخليجيه